well if you're wondering why you're not
losing weight in the areas that you need
it most it might because be because of
something called visceral fat fast Fit
Body scalping the sponsors of this
segment can help break it down and
joining us now is Doug Zuko Doug great
to see you again thanks for having me so
I just want to jump right into it tell
us a little bit about fast fit and what
it encompasses well I always love to
tell stories right so people always say
does fast get really work so I'd love to
tell a story so we have actually a photo
of a gentleman he's a military officer
he was working out all the time couldn't
lose weight end up hurting both
shoulders his name's Jose wow end up
hurting both shoulders so he couldn't go
to the gym anymore so he came to fast
fit in desperation
26 pounds of fat gone almost half of his
visceral fat gone on about four months
changed his life and saved his career
wow so coming off of an injury if you
can't work out this could be a solution
for you right or even if you can work
out yeah over if you're over age 35 we
just don't have the ability to lose
visceral fat like we did when we were
much younger right 35 is the age yeah so
if you're wondering why it's not working
anymore if you're you know over 35
that's probably why so come see you and
we talk about visceral fat a lot can you
tell me what that is and kind of break
it down for someone who doesn't really
know or understand absolutely the fat on
top right the fat we can pinch that's
subcutaneous fat means it's under the
skin okay but visceral fat is that deep
belly fat it's only in the midsection
it's behind the muscle so you can't feel
it if you grab hold of it you're just
feeling muscle but it's in there with
the organs and it creates a lot of
problems promote produces a lot of
estrogen the bad estrogen we don't want
also produces a lot of inflammation it
works as an organ against our health so
everything we don't want is from
visceral fat and it can be very very
dangerous okay that's really helpful to
kind of break it down and understand
because we always talk about it like I
know we need to to understand and
process kind of exactly what you guys do
and I know we have a few other photos
here of showing some before and afters
the one that we just saw was incredible
who are we looking at here this is Jade
and Jade at age 60 lost 30 and a half
pounds of pure fat seven inches off her
belly button look at her shape look at
the skin quality she looks like she's in
her 30s she looks incredible how much
was that you said 30 and a half wow pure
fat not body weight pure fat well looks
great all right who are we looking at
here now and this is Lisa and Lisa's 33
pounds of fat gone five inches off of
her belly button measurement but look at
the back fat all those wrinkles and
folds are gone skin looks great yeah it
looks nice and smooth and tight right
any recovery or down time if you go
through the process absolutely not
there's
lots of it all okay it's all very
healthy there's no negative side effects
at all everything's positive wow okay I
think we're
able to to show kind of before and after
here
brand new store I don't even have I
don't even have Photoshop like this is
after 21 days okay Teresa has lost
13.6 pounds of fat in only 21 days three
weeks I was gonna say that's a lot in a
short amount of time right so it's
possible not just body weight I'm
talking about pounds of pure fat wow she
actually gained three pounds of muscle
oh my gosh are you lose fat gained
muscle that's great right that's exactly
what happened and if people want to come
and get a consultation and learn more do
you recommend they're just coming into
the office call 1-800 fast fit set up a
time so we can have a consultation right
now we have an amazing offer for first
20 callers up to 60 off but the thing is
about faster just come and learn what we
do because when people come in and hear
and get to learn what we do they just
say one thing this makes sense well Doug
thank you so much for always breaking it
all down for us all the information on
your screen thank you to fastfit Body
Sculpting for sponsoring the segment you
can call 1-800 fast fit or visit
fastfit.com and they have a special
offer as you said the first 20 callers
can get up to 60 off their services
we'll be right back